so a couple of months ago we did a video
on the old Sun 3160 that I found lying
around in the department and trying to
get it to work and we sort of left it to
the point where it was making an awful
racket now we worked out that the noise
was actually coming from the old hard
disks which they're more like sanding
devices rather than actually harder to
look also to inspect their shot so we
took them out and if we turn it on now
it's still noisy but if they're it's got
less of a sort of angle grinder effect
to it and we've actually now got it to
the point where short of installing the
operating system it's still booting what
we've done is running in it now one of
these which is a scuzzy emulator
which uses a micro SD card to active the
hard-disk so I've set that up to
actually act as a hardest interesting
with the way I've set that up is I use
an emulator on the Mac to emulate the
hardware and installed the first part of
the operating system on that for that
sort of working now and I can get it as
far as booting and get it to boot into
the preliminary stages and even get it
able to ping out onto the local network
which is called collective internet so
actually on the internet they're just
booting up using the Falcon as the
terminal emulator and in a second
hopefully it'll ask me to enter the
menus and I should be able to get it
going so now into the View menu I'm
going to come out of the user return to
the monitor and I'm now going to boot it
off the scuzzy emulator so if du s T
naught comma 1 comma naught
so it's starting to boot I think that
was note there's actually now I'm trying
to do a network but which is not going
to do remember the right boob command we
can actually get it to Berlin and see
that's now booting into because Edith
squirm which is what's being emulated
Communications have changed it's now
moved from one theory or protocol to
another so just have to change the
settings of the port seven bits rather
than eight bit and I'm now actively
installer prompt salmon installed the
whole operation the other one jeans
booting so it's just a matter now of
installing everything and it would work
and if we look the internet connection
is up so we can actually set this with a
actual IP address so we can say what I
have conflict ie 0 to be up at 23.5 net
max
set that up and it's not picking
anything up so obviously I need to put
the other end of the network cabling
how does if you plug your internet
connection in so we're not going to plug
the internet connection in under the
floor we'll pull that one out
oops that was the cloud you want to shut
these lights flashing on the little box
you've actually got a little convertor
box here which is converting the 10 base
T coming out that into the a ey snake
you for the Sun and we've got a link and
got power and so on so hopefully I
should be able to bring that up and your
favorite oh yes no isn't a half on that
and so on please yeah if config is zero
has got an IP address now so hopefully I
should be able to ping the Rooter but
their pings do telnet or have any IP
what do I have but the very minimal
installation so far we normally saw the
whole thing so I don't even though how
about anything I can use to press the
internet connection not much there
TF PP v group look but if I do go to
another machine and see when this isn't
the one I unplugged I should be able to
ping that IP address now I can't maybe
see the Machine I unplugged
it worked the other day I know that's
not I'm running nothing getting there we
just killed it
someone slightly adapted inside my job
but I'm sure there it seemed actually
that the converter seems that all the
lights have gone off on it so I'm not
quite sure what's happening there will
keep her historic restoration and keep
you posted
I think so we have try this on the
device even get this working and then
see whether it's a clock with this
always before with the actual which is
the power going to it but energy to work
in either network card so I'm a suspect
wrong with this
did once with k3 it's encrypted another
time with k2 and when it's encrypted a
final time with k1 now let's think about
what that means it means that only this
dirty job but someone's got to do it